SPEAKER 1: Mr. James Bowman
is the film and culture
critic for The
American Spectator
and the media columnist
for The New Criterion.
He also writes a weekly
column on the media
for The Epoch Times.
A graduate of Lebanon Valley
College in Pennsylvania
and Cambridge University,
he is a resident scholar
at the Ethics and Public Policy
Center in Washington, DC.
He previously taught
English and general studies
in London and Portsmouth,
England for nine years.
He returned to the United
States as American correspondent
for The Spectator
and later served
as the American editor of The
Times Literary Supplement.
He is the author of Honor:
A History and Media Madness:
the Corruption of our
Political Culture.
Please welcome James Bowman.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMES BOWMAN: Thank you.
There's no knowing for sure--
of course, I may be wrong--
but I doubt that Jane Austen
would have quite approved
of the movies.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
We know from Penny Gay's
Jane Austen and the Theater
that she was a keen theatergoer,
whenever she had the chance,
and was even quite
undiscriminating in her taste,
which ranged from Edmund Kean
as Shylock in Drury Lane in 1814
to the lurid melodramas of
which we find several parodies
among her juvenilia.
But there is and always
has been a titillating,
voyeuristic quality to the
movies, a sense of the camera's
inevitable intrusion into
personal and domestic privacy
that must have made
moving pictures
more like the amateur dramatics
and amateur actors of which we
know from their treatment
in Mansfield Park
that she disapproved.
There, in arguing against the
amateur performance of Lovers'
Vows, a play about extramarital
sex and illegitimacy,
Edmund Bertram pleads
against his brother
Tom's contention that their
absent father would approve
of it because he approved of
their declaiming Shakespeare
when they were boys.
"My father wished us as
schoolboys to speak well,"
says Edmund.
"But he would never wish
his grown-up daughters
to be acting plays.
His sense of decorum is strict."
So was Jane Austen's
sense of decorum
strict, like that
of her alter ego,
Fanny Price, in the novel,
who adamantly refuses
to take part in the play.
Lionel Trilling thought this had
to do with Fanny's and probably
also her creator's horror
at the insincerity of anyone
like the temperamentally
inclined actor
Henry Crawford, who
could relish pretending
to be someone he was not.
It is the actor in him, examples
of which we see off the stage
as well as on, as when
he imagines himself
to be a naval hero or a
spellbinding preacher,
that makes Fanny mistrust him.
And of course,
females on the stage
were widely and
not always wrongly
suspected of
unchastity for as long
as there had been females
on the English stage, which
was for just over a century
before Jane Austen was born.
But I think there's
another reason why
she might not have approved of
the movies or of television.
This lies in what I believe to
be the central paradox of Jane
Austen's novels.
It's certainly true that
she prized sincerity.
"My Emma," says Mr. Knightley
to the eponymous heroine
of that novel,
"does not everything
serve to prove more and more the
beauty of truth and sincerity
in all our dealings
with each other?"
But there was another
virtue that she
prized even more highly.
And that, from one
point of view, at least,
is the very antithesis
of sincerity.
And that is the virtue of
what she calls self-command.
"Oh, that my dear mother had
more command over herself,"
laments Jane Bennet
in Pride and Prejudice
when her dear mother keeps
giving her painful reminders
of her having been forsaken, as
she supposes, by Mr. Bingley.
Self-command was particularly
important for women
because the inability to
suppress her feelings of regard
or attachment for a man, at
least until he was prepared
to offer her has his hand
and fortune in marriage,
was likely to lead a woman into
unchastity and consequent ruin,
as it does Maria Bertram in
Mansfield Park and Isabella
Thorpe in Northanger
Abbey, and almost
does Marianne Dashwood
in Sense and Sensibility
and Lydia Bennett in
Pride and Prejudice.
It may seem hard
for us to reconcile
such suppression
of one's feelings
with the truth and sincerity
in all our dealings
recommended by Mr.
Knightley, but I
don't think it was hard for Jane
Austen or her contemporaries.
Our first requirement for
appreciating her, therefore,
either on the page
or on the screen,
is for ourselves to
try to understand
the importance for the
kind of moral seriousness
of which Jane Austen is
always an advocate, of what we
would nowadays call the
repression of powerful emotion.
The first time I
was asked to compare
the various cinematic
or televisual versions
of her works was in the
millennium year of 2000,
before many of you were born and
was at the request of something
called the Independent Women's
Quarterly, a publication now
no longer in existence,
I'm sorry to say.
Of the screen versions of
her novels then existing,
I chose the 1993 adaptation
of Sense and Sensibility,
written by Emma Thompson
and directed by Ang Lee,
as the best.
You'll have a chance
to see it on Tuesday,
and I think I can promise
you a treat in store,
if you haven't
seen it, including
fine performances by Kate
Winslet as Marianne Dashwood,
the late Alan Rickman
as Colonel Brandon,
Imelda Staunton as Mrs. Palmer,
Hugh Laurie as Mr. Palmer,
Imogen Stubbs as Lucy Steele,
and Greg Wise as Willoughby.
Even Hugh Grant as Edward
Ferrars, who you would think
would be all wrong
for the part, manages
to make the blockish Edward
almost plausibly lovable
by poor Eleanor--
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
--who is played by
Emma Thompson herself.
And it was her performance
that, more than anyone else's,
which was the making of
the film, in my opinion.
Her heroic self-command in the
face of the twin calamities
of her sister's indiscretions
with Willoughby and Lucy
Steele's entrusting her with
the un-revealable secret
that the man she loves is
engaged to another literally
keeps her family together.
And it is rewarded at
the end in a scene which,
as I wrote at the time, it is
impossible to watch unmoved,
when a diffident, po-faced
Edward reveals that he is not,
as everyone had supposed,
married to Lucy Steele.
Didn't she know that Lucy had
married his brother instead?
Didn't everyone know it?
At this point, the
hitherto impassive
Eleanor, rigid
with self-command,
suddenly bursts into
convulsive sobs that
continue as her mother and
sisters leave the room, leaving
Edward and his long-despaired-of
proposals with Eleanor.
The whole movie,
the whole struggle
between Eleanor's sense
and Marianne's sensibility,
the whole of Jane
Austen, in a way,
is present in that moment of
the epiphany, when self-command
like a dam breaking
finally gives way,
because it can give way to
the pent-up emotion behind it.
I remember reading somewhere--
alas, I cannot remember where--
that in Jane Austen's day,
the English were looked on
by the rest of Europe the way
the Italians were later to be,
as typically emotionally
incontinent--
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
--wearing their hearts
on their sleeves,
as my father used to call it--
and unashamed to weep in public.
It was supposedly only
in the Victorian era
that the famous British stiff
upper lip came into being,
especially for men,
and the ability
to suppress one's feelings
became a marker of manhood
as well as politesse.
I'm not sure that this is true.
At the first meeting in
several months of the brothers
Knightley in Emma, we read
that, "'How do you do, George?'
And 'John, how are you?'
succeeded in the true English
style, burying under a
calmness that seemed to all
but indifference the real
attachment which would have led
either of them, if requisite,
to do everything for the good
of the other."
Self-command is as important
for men as for women,
in other words, as a mark of
good breeding and good manners.
You may have noticed
something of this kind
of emotional restraint which
was still typical of the English
within living memory in the
version of Pride and Prejudice
that was shown
here this afternoon
and which was made during
the Second World War,
when British upper lips had
to be at their stiffest.
The film's emotional reticence
is particularly noticeable
if you compare it with such
more recent versions as the 1995
six-part BBC adaptation by
Andrew Davis, or the feature
film of 10 years later
by Joe Wright with Keira
Knightley as a
feisty postfeminist
Elizabeth Bennet
and Matthew Mcfadyen
as a lummox-y, hangdog Darcy.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
Laurence Olivier, the
Darcy in the 1940 version
of Pride and Prejudice,
was thought, at the time,
to represent
something of a break
with the old declamatory
style of acting
more appropriate to
the stage in favor
of a more realistic manner
demanded by the movies.
But his Darcy seems
to me to be an example
not so much of
emotional suppression as
of emotional absence.
More generally, the
film skates over all
the novel's emotional
depths, as we have since
learned to see them,
and treats it, instead,
is nothing but a rollicking
comedy of manners, something
also evident in the
extreme liberties
that the Hollywood of that
period took with the text.
Most shocking of which, in my
view, is its making the visit
of Lady Catherine de
Bourgh, Edna May Oliver,
to Greer Garson's Elizabeth
on the eve of their engagement
to Darcy as a put-up job between
the old lady and her nephew
to test the younger woman
for any mercenary motive she
might have in accepting him.
This doesn't even make
sense from the point
of view of the plot,
since her earlier refusal
of Darcy's proposal
should have put to rest
any suspicions of that sort.
My own suspicion is that the
screenwriter, Aldous Huxley,
raised in
stiff-upper-lip Britain
and working on a
dramatization of the novel
by the Australian transplant
Helen Jerome, simply
took its theme of emotional
restraint and reserve
for granted.
The same is true, though,
to a lesser extent
if you go back and look at the
BBC'S adaptations of Persuasion
and Emma from 1971 and
1972, respectively,
in which the staginess of
early television drama,
especially in such
period pieces,
costume dramas such as these,
combined with what one can only
supposed to be the congenital
stiffness of the actors,
make them almost unwatchable
by present-day standards,
though they do have the
virtue of including more,
if it is a virtue,
including more
of the text than most versions.
Yet in their stiffness
and formality of manner
and apparent lack of
feeling, these 1970s versions
of Jane Austen must
be closer to the way
she herself would have
envisaged her characters
than later versions.
The more important way in which
they go astray, in my opinion,
is that they treat the novels
as being satirical in a way
that Jane Austen was
not, or not in the sense
as we now understand the term.
In other words, they see her
as a satirist of social class
distinctions and
snobbery, things
that were of greater
concern in the last century
than they were in Jane Austen's
time, more than they are now,
now that our political
attention has turned
to more interesting classes of
the self-identified oppressed,
than those who merely
lacked leisure,
social prestige, or money.
But Jane Austen, I think, has
no political axes to grind.
She takes distinctions of
social class for granted.
And it would never occur
to her to ridicule others
who do the same.
Though some may give too much
importance to social standing,
like Lady Russell in
Persuasion, of whom it is
said that she had "a value
for rank and consequence
which blinded her a little
to the faults of those
who possess them."
Corin Redgrave of the Socialist
Workers' Party and the famously
radical Redgrave
family, hamming it up
as the snobbish Sir Walter
Elliot in the 1995 Persuasion,
so much so that he's almost
allowed to overshadow the love
story of Anne and
Captain Wentworth,
may have been the last gasp of
this mid-century view of Jane
Austen as social satirist.
But the sudden spate of
cinematic adaptations
of her novels in the 1990s
and after the 20th century's
obsession with social class
had largely spent itself,
was the result, I believe, of a
renewed interest in Jane Austen
the moralist, which is also how
she was seen in her own time.
This is important
because there has never
been a time in the
English-speaking world when
we've been more in
need of moral guidance,
now that we have a new
ideologically based morality
every day further displacing
the traditional kind, the Jane
Austen kind, and assuming
cultural dominance over us.
The linguist and social
philosopher John McWhorter
does not scruple to call this
so-called "woke consciousness"
a new religion.
I would prefer to
call it an ideology.
And the intellectual
attraction of ideology,
unlike that of the religion,
which as you may remember used
to tell us that we
were all sinners,
is that if you only believe,
you can never be wrong.
The ideologue will allow
you to speak of yourself
as being on the
right side of history
because you may assume
that you already
know how history will come out.
Your ideology informs
you of this in advance.
And you can use your
supposed knowledge
of your support your supposed
rightness about everything
to shame those who are
still among the doubters.
You can tell them, as the actor
Sean Penn did at the Oscars
a few years ago, that
their grandchildren will
be ashamed of them
for having resisted
the tide of moral certainty
that must certainly carry all
before it into the future.
In other words, our
ideologically-dominated society
is as morally primitive as it
is scientifically advanced.
Even non-ideologues tend to
take the view, as who would not
who had never been told
that there was anything
to stop them, that both
morality and science are all
about being right, when
they both are much,
much more about being wrong?
We pull our morality,
like our science,
around us as if they were
a cloak of invulnerability
for our opinions.
When properly understood,
both are instead
the instruments of those
opinion's dissections
and very often, destruction.
Some years ago, the
journalist Kathryn Schulz
wrote a book called
Being Wrong: Adventures
in the Margin of Error,
in which she invented
a new science of wrongology.
I recommend it to you as one
of the most important books
of our century.
But Jane Austen was
there ahead of her.
As I see them, and
as I hope you will,
her novels all focus
on a moral moment
that can only be
called dramatic, which
is why they're adapted so well
to the screen in our time,
and why they have taken
on a new relevance
and cogency to so many in the
very, very different world
of two centuries later.
This is what I call
the I was wrong moment.
All of her heroines
and most of her heroes
have to suffer through the
mortification of an I was wrong
moment.
Fanny Price and Anne Elliot are
partial exceptions, but only
partial.
Although Fanny is never
far from self-doubt,
she is only ever wrong
about being wrong,
which is to say she's
wrong about her occasional
doubtful I was wrong moments and
right about the Crawfords when
everyone else is
telling her she's wrong.
She's right, too,
about Maria and Julia's
faults of immodesty and
right about who Edmund really
loves, though she tries
hardest to talk herself
into being wrong about this.
It is Edmund who has
to pass through the I
was wrong fire most scorchingly.
And that, I think,
robs this novel
of some of the
poignancy of the others,
wherein female wrongness
seems to me, by contrast,
to carry with it the conviction
of personal experience.
Anne Elliot's I was
wrong moment takes place
before the action
of the novel begins,
when she realizes that she
was wrong to have yielded
to Lady Russell's
persuasion in breaking off
her engagement to Captain
Wentworth, which means that it
is Wentworth who experiences
Persuasion's main I was
wrong moment in realizing after
Louisa Musgrove's accident
that the firmness of purpose,
which Louisa has and Anne is
supposed to lack, is not, after
all, unleavened by prudence,
the most desirable
quality in a woman,
and that it is only
his own pride which
has kept him from returning
to his first love.
Here, as in Mansfield
Park, the main I
was wrong moments
being predicated
of her principal male
characters, makes
the dramatizations
of both novels,
compared with the others,
less successful, in my view,
perhaps, because it's less
unexpected when a man turns out
to be wrong--
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
--or at least when
he admits to it.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
This may also be why
Patricia Rozema, in her 1999
version of Mansfield
Park, felt she
had to jazz up Jane with
a completely gratuitous
polemic against slavery
on Sir Thomas Bertram's
plantations in Antigua,
something about which
her Fanny, played
by Frances O'Connor,
obviously finds it as easy to
be right as we do in retrospect.
And the same goes for the many
little feminist applause lines
that even the best of the
movie and TV adaptations
can't resist adding
occasionally to the original.
I've already
mentioned the mistake,
as I see it, in the 1995
version of Persuasion's implied
self-congratulation
by concentrating
too much on the obvious but
never acknowledged wrongness
of Sir Walter, as opposed to the
less obvious but more painfully
realized wrongness
of Captain Wentworth.
Sir Walter is just one of the
many characters in the novels
who serve as a foil
or as foils to the I
was wrong characters by being
like today's ideologues,
incapable of seeing
themselves in the wrong,
no matter how wrong they are.
Not all these
characters are villains
like Sir Walter, or General
Tilney, or William Elliott,
or the Crawfords.
Some only come in for more
or less gentle ridicule,
like Mr. Collins, or Mrs.
Elton, or Mrs. Bennet.
But what they all have in
common is self-assurance.
Self-assurance is
self-command, but
without that other
great Austenian virtue
of self-knowledge.
Unaware of itself,
self-assurance
takes its own
mannerly insincerity
for the warmest
sympathy, or even, as
in Henry Crawford's case, love.
Therefore, it is immune
to the self-doubt that
is the trial through which all
Jane Austen's heroines have
to pass.
Nowadays, we might call
such self-assurance "cool."
Henry Crawford is
certainly a very cool guy.
So is Mr. William
Elliot in Persuasion.
John Thorpe of Northanger
Abbey is a mere buffoon,
like so many Oxford men--
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
--trying, without
success, to be a cool guy.
But all of them share what
Jane Austen herself most often
refers to as
self-conceit or vanity,
not that is Sir Walter's
kind of personal vanity
of personal
appearance so much as
that which she attributes
to Henry Crawford
when he is said to have "had
all the disposition to persevere
that Sir Thomas could wish him."
He had vanity, which strongly
inclined him in the first place
to think that
Fanny did love him,
although she might
not know it herself.
This kind of vanity is
the salient characteristic
of all her villains and
her objects of ridicule,
both the cool and the uncool,
like Mr. Collins in Pride
and Prejudice or
Mr. Elton in Emma,
the two latter being clergymen,
interestingly, rather than
actors.
Frank Churchill of Emma
is also a very cool guy.
And so, as Mr. Knightley
points out, not to be trusted.
But he escapes absolute villainy
by sufficient self-knowledge
to be always aware of
his putting on an act
and of having a very
particular object in doing so.
And also by knowing, even as he
does so, that putting on an act
is wrong.
He is maybe the only character
in the Jane Austen corpus who
is both culpably
self-assured and capable
of a sincerely penitential
I was wrong moment,
of at least partial
self-redemption.
Darcy might be
another candidate,
except that his self-assurance
is less culpable and less
calculating and his confession
of error more sincere.
Willoughby in Sense
and Sensibility
is an interesting
case in this respect,
in a scene which was, for
understandable reasons,
cut from the movie,
we will see him
appearing before Eleanor
penitent about his treatment
of Marianne and
pleading with her
for a measure of forgiveness.
This scene is obviously
meant to be taken as sincere
on his part, but he has
not the self-knowledge
of Claudius in Hamlet who,
in his penitential scene,
asks himself, "May one
be pardoned and retain
the offense?"
He is, unfortunately,
still possessed
of those effects, a rich wife
and an end to indebtedness
as well as a reconciliation
with his aunt, for which he
jilted Marianne.
His regret, what he had to
give up for them, having been
insufficient to prevent him
from taking the moral course,
has become something
he will have to live
with for the rest of his life.
The crime, as Eleanor
observes, carries
with it its own punishment.
All this the movie
reduces to a single shot
at the very end of Willoughby,
all alone on horseback,
looking sadly down from a
nearby hill on the scene
of the double wedding.
Just as self-assurance
is characteristic of all
the bad or ridiculous
people in her novels,
so is self-doubt and
self-correction characteristic
of all her heroes and
especially her heroines.
Her portrayal of her
unerring instinct
for what the Greeks
called the peripeteia,
or reversal in the dramatic
I was wrong moment,
is what makes her novels, as
well as the best of the movies
or miniseries based
on them, peculiarly
relevant to our time.
I think it's no coincidence
that the two most often
and most successfully adapted
novels, Pride and Prejudice
and Emma, are also the two with
the most and the most affecting
I was wrong moments.
The final chapters of
Pride and Prejudice
are a positive
riot of wrongness,
beginning with Jane's
being wrong about Bingley's
continuing and
constant regard for her
and Bingley's being wrong
about her lack of same for him.
But this is nothing
next to Elizabeth
constantly trying to talk
herself into being wrong,
for the second time, but
in the opposite direction,
about Darcy's feelings for
her, until she discovers
that she was wrong about
being wrong from Darcy's
confession to her about all
the ways he was wrong until she
herself put him right.
Then, when both daughters
and their fiancés have sorted
the right from the wrong,
they have to put their family,
father, mother, sisters, right
about the ways they have been
wrong about Lizzie's
supposed hatred of Darcy.
All this without mentioning
the superlative wrongness
of Catherine Bingley--
or Caroline Bingley's, sorry--
lady Catherine De Bourgh,
and Mr. Collins, none of whom
has the capacity to recognize
his or her own wrongness.
Not a character escapes
the pitfalls of wrongness
of one sort or
another, except perhaps
for Charlotte Lucas,
who is presumed
to have gone into her marriage
with Mr. Collins with her eyes
open to his many and
varied wrongnessess,
and closed to them thereafter.
And all the characters
are defined for us
by their reaction
to being wrong,
even when, as in the cases
of Mrs. Bennett, Lydia,
and Wickham, they can never
be got to acknowledge it.
Mrs. Bennett simply
ignores her own mistakes
when they are revealed
to her, and assumes
she's always thought of Bingley
and Darcy as she does now.
In this she is like Mrs.
Allen in Northanger Abbey
and Mr. Weston in
Emma, both of whom
keep saying I knew
it would be so,
when everything they
had said would be so
turns out to be wrong.
Mr. Bennett is a
particularly interesting case
in this respect, as
he is unusually ready
to admit to being wrong, but
at the same time feels it
less, or less lastingly,
than anyone else in the novel
with that capacity.
In confessing to his
own fault and the laxity
of parental control, which has
resulted in Lydia's elopement
with Wickham, he
says to Elizabeth,
"Who should suffer but myself?
It has been my own doing
and I ought to feel it."
"You must not be too severe
upon yourself," Lizzie replies.
"You may well warn me against
such an evil," he says.
"Human nature is so
prone to fall into it.
No, Lizzie.
Let me once in my life feel
how much I have been to blame.
I'm not afraid of being
overpowered by the impression.
It will pass away soon enough."
The comedy of
interlacing wrongnessess
in these final chapters and
the almost farcical quality
of our delight in Miss
Austen's unraveling of them
to make everything turn
out incredibly right
must be why this has always been
the most popular of her novels,
and why its various adaptations
have been on the whole
the most successful.
The best of these has still
got to be that 1995 BBC
version in six parts
with Colin Firth as Darcy
and Jennifer Ehle as Elizabeth,
not to mention the great Alison
Steadman as the Mrs. Bennett,
and all Misses Bennets.
But the connoisseur
of wrongness,
which I hope you are all
beginning to be by now,
must always have a
special place in his heart
for Emma, since Emma Woodhouse
is by far the wrongest of all
her heroines, more wrong
even than the hopelessly
naive and four years
younger Catherine
Moreland in Northanger
Abbey, at least half
of whose wrongness
passes unnoticed by her,
and remains a private
joke between the author
and her readers.
Emma hasn't Catherine's
excuse for going wrong,
which may be why Jane Austen
thought that nobody would much
like her but herself.
The number of adaptations
of the novel in recent years
suggests that she
was wrong about this.
But is that because we like her?
Do we like her because or in
spite of her numerous errors?
Let's try to count them up.
First, as Mr. Knightley points
out to her in chapter one,
she's wrong to
think that she has
arranged the match between
Mr. Weston and Miss Taylor.
Then she's wrong about
Harriet and Robert Martin,
wrong about Harriet
and Mr. Elton,
and Frank Churchill.
Wrong finally about
Harriet and Mr. Knightley.
And each of these major errors
comprises numerous lesser ones,
like all those
instances of which
she is so eager to mistake
Mr. Elton's little attentions
to Harriet before her eyes are
opened as to their real object.
And then there are her mistakes
about Frank Churchill herself,
about Jane Fairfax and
Mr. Dixon, Jane Fairfax
and the mysterious
present of the pianoforte,
and most momentously, but like
everybody else in Highbury,
her being wrong about
Jane and Frank Churchill--
part of what leads her
to be wrong in her insult
to Miss Bates, a mistake
also pointed out to her
by Mr. Knightley.
His and the Westons
being wrong about her
and Frank Churchill
appears a mere trifle
next to the number of Emma's
wrong thoughts and deeds,
every one of which she has to
face up to sooner or later.
Though her final mistake
about Mr. Knightley's feelings
for her are as happily
wrong as Lizzie Bennet's
about Mr. Darcy's
feelings for her.
Actually there is
one species of error
that she's not shown
as facing up to,
though it may be that we are
meant to understand she does
as it takes place in private.
Perhaps her
self-correction is allowed
to take place off the page.
But when she rages to
herself about Mr. Elton's
misdirected proposal,
she abuses him to herself
for exactly the
fault of aspiring
to rise above his
social level that he
had abused Harriet Smith for.
So much to her annoyance.
This, in turn, reminds us of
her snobbery towards Mr. Martin,
though it does
not so remind her.
She still thinks she was
right to break off that match.
The failure here is
one of self-awareness,
of not being able to
see when she's blaming
others for her own faults.
The dawning of
self-awareness is the rarest
and most spiritually significant
of all I was wrong moments,
but in Emma it takes
its most benign form
when after Harriet
confesses what
she takes to be, wrongly
of course, an attachment
to Mr. Knightley, it
darted through her
with the speed of an arrow
that Mr. Knightley must
marry no one but herself.
Here at last we are
told is the beginning
of that knowledge
of herself that
can only come with a recognition
that she has been, quote,
"totally ignorant
of her own heart."
So which is the best
screen version of Emma?
There is much to be said
for Gwyneth Paltrow as Emma
in Douglas McGrath's
movie of 1996, which
you may see tomorrow, but
it goes badly wrong itself
in taking one of Emma's
wrongnesses away from her
and giving it to Frank
Churchill instead.
This is the suspicion about
Jane Fairfax and Mr. Dixon,
which in this version is
proposed by Frank instead
of being Emma's
surmise, which is out
of her natural love of intrigue.
In other words, it's a lie.
More seriously,
Miss Paltrow's I was
wrong moments are almost
as anodyne as those
of her alter ego in Amy
Heckerling's Clueless, which
came out at about the same time.
There, the Emma character
called Cher, and played
by Alicia Silverstone,
makes only comic errors,
while her very brief
I was wrong moment
is smoothed away and
rendered unimportant
by the emollient words of a
very implausible Mr. Knightley
character played by
the young Paul Rudd.
Miss Paltrow's Emma may
say that she's wrong,
but we never really
see anything that
looks very much like a
dart of self-knowledge
hitting her with the
speed of an arrow.
On the plus side, Ewan McGregor
makes a very plausibly caddish
Frank Churchill, Alan Cumming
is the most comically unctuous
of all possible Mr. Eltons,
and Jeremy Northam the most
Mr. Knightley-like Mr.
Knightley that I have seen.
Toni Collette has in some ways
the most interesting Harriet,
too, but she's too
much over the top,
like an embryo Mrs.
Bennett, and not
a plausible love interest
for any of the suitors
to whom Emma would assign her,
or even the allegedly sensible
Robert Martin.
The most beautiful, as
Harriet is described
in the novel, as well as the
most charmingly dim Harriet I
have seen is Louise Dylan in
the 2009 BBC miniseries, which
also has by far the best Mr.
Woodhouse in Michael Gambon,
and a very decent Emma
and Knightley in Romola
Garai and Johnny Lee Miller.
Like all mini-series
it also has room
to squeeze in far
more of the novel
and all its riches than
a feature film can do.
As for the last
year's film of Emma
directed by Autumn deWilde,
I hated almost everything
about it.
Beginning with the wide-eyed,
gamine-like, almost babydoll
look of Anya Taylor Joy's Emma.
Indeed, I hated the looks of
all the main characters except
for Miranda Hart's
Miss Bates, who
was perhaps the best
in that role I've seen.
I also hated the way Bill
Nighy's Mr. Woodhouse enters
leaping, as if to stick
a thumb in the eye
of every other portrayal of
him as a valetudinarian, as in,
you know, the novel.
I hated the way the supposedly
manly Mr. Knightley, age 37,
played by 37-year-old
Johnny Flynn,
acts like a lovesick teenager,
pumping his fist in the air
and showing his apparent
lack of self-command
in every emotion
he openly feels.
Not at all, in other words,
in the true English style
as described by Jane Austen.
I hated the self-conscious
exaggeration
of every comic effect, and the
obtrusive musical pointing,
with a jumble of Irish-sounding
folk music, choral church
music, and bits of Haydn,
Mozart, and Beethoven.
But when it comes
to the wrongology
of Emma's various
self-epiphanies,
especially when she responds
to Mr. Knightley proposal,
with a look of one absolutely
poleaxed with dawning
self-awareness, her almost
comically wide-set eyes finally
coming into their own.
Moreover, a spontaneous
nosebleed on the occasion
seems no more than an
appropriate reminder
of the wounding and
death and rebirth
that the penitential
process mimics.
Not to mention the arrow
of self-awareness darting
through her, as I
mentioned earlier.
This, the greatest of the
cinematic I was wrong moments,
is good enough to make me think
that all those other things
that I disliked about the
movie might be deliberate
exercises in
wrongology themselves.
There's no doubt, at any
rate, that I too can be wrong.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: Thank
you, Mr. Bowman.
We now have time for some
Q&A. If you have a question,
please make your way
to the microphones.
SPEAKER 3: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
That was really
a wonderful talk.
I just was really intrigued by
what you mentioned at the end.
I'm sorry-- is this better.
JAMES BOWMAN: That's
better, thank you.
SPEAKER 3: Thank you.
I have not seen all
of the new Emma movie,
but I was not a fan of
it, just because it seemed
to be making fun of the book.
But I was intrigued
by what you said
that maybe it was
all just following
the wrongness ideology.
JAMES BOWMAN: It was all what?
SPEAKER 3: That maybe that was
just the wrongness ideology,
maybe?
JAMES BOWMAN: Wrongology.
SPEAKER 3: The
wrongology, that maybe all
of those other seemingly
errors were just
part of that
wrongology, and so I
was wondering if you could
expand a little bit on that.
JAMES BOWMAN: Well, when
somebody does something
so right, you kind of
look back and think
of all the other things
that they've done wrong
in a different light.
It seems to me.
I just-- I needed
to see it again,
obviously, after that ending,
because I thought, well,
if she does this
right, then maybe she
was doing the other
things right that I
thought she was doing wrong.
Maybe she could only have
produced this brilliant effect
at the end by doing all
the other things wrong
that I thought she did wrong.
SPEAKER 4: Hi.
I really enjoyed that lecture.
At the beginning
you said something
along the lines of Jane Austen
taking the social classes
for granted in
her stories, and I
was wondering if you could
expand a little bit more
on what you meant
by that statement.
JAMES BOWMAN: Well,
they were a fact
of life, the social gradations.
There's-- in the 2007 version
of Pride and Prejudice,
there is some attempt,
I think it's 2006.
2007?
Anyway, it's the one
with Keira Knightley
and Donald Sutherland as
a really not very good
Mr. Bennett.
But there was a lot
of effort in that--
I should have mentioned that--
to cast or turn the
camera on the servants
and the lower-class
people who are taken
for granted in most of the
most versions of Jane Austen,
as a reminder that these
people live the way
they live because of
the labors of people
that they look down on.
That's a very modern
way of looking at it.
I think as best I can tell,
it's not Jane Austen's way.
She too would take the
servants for granted.
She too would recognize
that, as Mr. Elton says,
everyone has their level.
That it was a serious matter if
you married too far up or down
from the class you
were born into,
because it involved
your family, and that's
the point Mr. Darcy was
making about Lizzie's family.
It was a real consideration.
And I think it's one that
Jane Austen would have shared,
as she would most of
the things that seem
to us in our egalitarian age
a much more worrisome thing.
As I say, though, I think
we're kind of getting away
from that a little bit.
It's more of a
20th-century obsession,
this idea with social classes.
Now we have other classes
that we care more about.
Race, sex, sexual orientation,
all that sort of thing
is more important to us
than social hierarchies.
SPEAKER 5: Hi.
So at the very beginning
you talked about Austen
loving theater, but kind
of hating those amateur
plays that can be
just kind of base,
and so I was just wondering
if you could speak
a little bit about how she
writes these books that
are these moral books,
but then they always
have this kind of romantic,
or at least who's going
to marry who aspect to them.
And so kind of why that is a big
part of it when she's writing
such books about morality?
JAMES BOWMAN: When she's
writing books about?
SPEAKER 5: Morality.
JAMES BOWMAN: Well,
for a woman, that was
the supreme area of morality.
That was the morality
that mattered for women
more than anything else.
Because marriage mattered for
them more than anything else.
It was the only way
they could escape from--
I mean, women of the class that
Jane Austen is concerned with,
the only way they could hope
to leave their father's house
and move to a husband's house.
You couldn't just go out
on your own in those days,
and so marriage and
all that surrounds it,
including the emotions
of love, which
even then was pretty
important to people
in looking for
marital partners, this
became the central
concern of their lives.
That's what Mrs.
Bennett is all about.
I mean, she's a silly
woman, but she's only
doing what any woman
in her situation
would feel necessary
to do, which
is to get her daughters
married however she could,
because that's the only
way they could ever
be independent of her.
So morality for
a woman basically
concerned sex and marriage,
and that was pretty much it.
Yes?
SPEAKER 6: So you mentioned that
Mr. Darcy had a very sincere
confession of error.
Did you find any
other characters
in the other movies that had
similar sincerity moments?
JAMES BOWMAN: I'm sorry,
I missed the beginning.
SPEAKER 6: Did you think
that any other characters
in the Jane Austen
movies had moments
of sincerity similar to Mr.
Darcy's confession of error?
JAMES BOWMAN: Oh, yes.
Yes I think they all--
well, all the good ones.
They were all sincere, I think,
in confessing they're right.
I think there must be some doubt
about Frank Churchill being
totally sincere, anyway.
Claiming to have known all
along that he was doing wrong
but thinking that now that
he's got what he wanted to
by doing it he can apologize
and everything will be OK.
But I think in all the
other cases the sincerity is
pretty obvious.
There are other
occasions when people
confess to being wrong
when it isn't sincere.
I think Henry Crawford
is one example of that
in Mansfield Park where he says,
I'm wrong, I know I'm wrong,
tell me what's right to Fanny.
Which is just another way of
his trying to get around her,
get around her defenses.
Well, this is what she
wants, that's what I'll do.
But mostly the I
was wrong moment is
a moment of sincerity, I think.
Yes?
SPEAKER 7: OK, sir.
I thought a point you made
was very interesting about how
this element in Jane Austen's
novels about the characters
being wrong, and
realizing their wrongness
is one of the elements that
makes them good stories.
And then you brought up
some other film adaptions
that did not address that.
And he kind of skirted over
the issue of the characters
being wrong and them realizing.
And these were the
worst adaptions,
so do you think that
in this culture,
they purposely did not make the
characters address their wrong?
Like, do you think
that's some fear
on the part of the filmmakers
of admitting the fallibility
of their characters?
Or just what are your
thoughts on that?
JAMES BOWMAN: No, I
think that they just
didn't take it that seriously.
If you compare the movie that
was shown this afternoon,
Greer Garson's confession of
error seems almost gratuitous.
I mean partly that's because
of the constraints of the film,
but one minute she's saying I
hate you, the next minute she's
saying I love him.
What happened?
It can't all be down
to just that in getting
put right about Wickham.
But it's just--
it's passed over,
I think partly because
mainly because it
was conceived of as a comedy.
It was-- don't want
the laughing to stop.
We don't want to get
too serious here.
We don't want to say,
oh, my god, I was wrong.
We were just, oh,
that was wrong,
and then we move on to
the next funny episode.
I think it's a way of looking
at a different-- looking
at it dramatically from a
different point of view,
as they did back in 1940,
and as I think now we're
more inclined to do, is it's
a more serious business when
we're wrong, and I think
we can understand it more.
Maybe they were just
more used to being wrong
back in those days.
SPEAKER 8: Hi there.
Thanks for your lecture.
It was really, really good.
The 1995 Pride and Prejudice
is objectively the best.
So.
JAMES BOWMAN: What?
SPEAKER 8: The 1995
Pride and Prejudice
is objectively the best.
JAMES BOWMAN: Yes, yes.
I agree.
SPEAKER 8: So I
really like what you
were saying about the kind of
tension between self-knowledge
and what was the other?
It was self-command.
I think.
JAMES BOWMAN: Self-command, yes.
SPEAKER 8: Yeah, and
I was just wondering
what insights you think Jane
Austen had as to those two
virtues, I suppose.
Did she have a
sense of which one
was more commonly difficult
for a man to achieve,
or which one was more difficult
for a woman to achieve,
or is it just kind of
case-by-case basis?
Are these virtues sometimes
more masculine and easier
for men to achieve?
I mean, I think that
Darcy seems to have
some appearance of self-command,
but no self-knowledge.
But then you could even
argue that he doesn't
have self-command
because he can't really
show who he really is.
JAMES BOWMAN: No, that
showing who you really are
is not a good thing
in Jane Austen.
But I think you're right to
say that it's easier to assume
it of a man than of a woman.
For Jane Austen, I hesitate.
Or, I hasten to add
that partly because it's
an ideological thing.
This is the point of
Sense and Sensibility,
that Marianne is a
spokesman for a--
or a spokeswoman for a-- new
way of looking at emotion.
It was called
sensibility and it was
a movement of the
Romantic period,
and she's a very
romantic woman who
thought that people ought
to show their feelings.
It's a bad thing
to repress them.
It's the beginnings
of our more modern way
of looking at things.
And Jane Austen is standing
pretty firmly against that,
and saying this is what happens.
This is what happens
when you do that,
when you let your let your
feelings show who you really
are.
Don't want to do that.
No.
Particularly if you're a woman.
It leads to all
kinds of trouble.
Yes.
SPEAKER 9: Oh, OK.
So I was wondering, what are
your thoughts on that idea
of wrongness in Lady Susan?
I mean, because that's one
of the only novels that
has someone who is that wrong.
JAMES BOWMAN: Yeah.
Yeah, you're right.
And that's sort of why I
didn't mention Lady Susan.
Because it completely
overthrows everything I said.
No.
No, it's-- I see Lady
Susan as apprentice work.
Basically, she's learning her
trade when she wrote that.
And I think she frankly
delighted in someone as wicked
as Lady Susan Vernon, and she
just enjoyed that creation.
She wasn't really in her
moralistic vein at that stage.
She was just playing around
with the idea of someone who
could be that calculating
and that wicked,
and showing it in sort
of the indirect way
through the epistolary style.
It is-- but you're
right, it is--
it's certainly unusual
in the whole corpus.
She never wrote like
that [? away ?] again.
SPEAKER 2: OK, this
is our last question.
JAMES BOWMAN: Sure.
SPEAKER 10: Hello.
Thank you, that was great.
Thank you, Mr. Bowman.
You spoke of Jane Austen as
a moralist and the moralist
we need.
But there's moralism and
there's moralism, right?
And with Jane
Austen, I just mean
there's certain
kinds of moralism
that you don't want
to sit through.
But you don't really feel Jane
Austen's moralism as a burden,
I guess?
JAMES BOWMAN: As what?
SPEAKER 10: A burden.
It's--
JAMES BOWMAN: A burden?
SPEAKER 10: Yes.
JAMES BOWMAN: You
don't feel it, though.
SPEAKER 10: What I'm
saying is, why do we
like Jane Austen's
moralism and not feel it
as sermonic or something?
Whereas there are many other
kinds of films and novels
that we don't have
patience with that
are trying to do
something similar.
JAMES BOWMAN: That's
a good question.
Well, I think it's because
she's so obviously sincere.
She's so obviously engaged
with these very serious
moral issues, and
not just preaching.
She's showing them in action.
She's showing how
people actually
make decisions, good and bad,
and how they get things wrong.
And then showing it in a
way that that's sympathetic.
She understands how
their minds are working.
She understands what's going on.
She's not laying down
the law and saying, oh,
isn't this terrible.
She's just showing us.
She just showing how it works.
And we recognize
that because we've
had similar experiences
ourselves, most of it.
And so it's not
preachy, as you say.
There's a great line
in Pride and Prejudice
about Mary, the
serious daughter who's
engaged in philosophical
studies and all that,
about her threadbare moralism.
She's the one that
always has a platitude
ready for every occasion,
about ah, this is wrong,
and this is right.
But nobody pays any attention
to her because it's just words.
It's just preaching.
Whereas what Jane
Austen is doing
is showing us the
thing in action.
And that we can all
relate to, I think.
SPEAKER 2: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]